starting off this hour Kate is in Denver
hi Kate welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up all right so I'm newly
married a little over a year and we have
a six-month-old and I guess I mean I can
share with you all the details but more
recently there's been growing tension I
guess we recently moved into a new home
and anytime I want to spend money on
paint or pillows or something like that
there's a you can be really annoyed by
it but it seems like a lot of the
expenses he'd like to do like elk
hunting or something like that you can
easily justify is like providing meat
for the family I guess I'm just feeling
like we're still in ghazal know and I
don't know if that's appropriate
well elk hunting and pillows neither one
would show up in Gazelle mode so are you
are you cos el mode is you're totally
focused on getting out of debt and so
you cut out any spending that is not
necessary to exist and you completely
cut your lifestyle to nothing and you
attack that is that what you're doing no
I think we're on step three so so you're
finishing your emergency fund right we
actually currently have 5,000 our
emergency fund so you're not done our
victory yeah okay right or we're in sub
three so so really what this comes down
to is an argument in a brand new
marriage between you don't feel like
your vote counts as much as he thinks
his vote counts I mean or I guess like I
feel like I'm constantly being asked can
you spend less can you some less like it
are you not involved in putting together
the budget with it so I guess the way
it's working now is he's kind of putting
it together and presenting it to me but
since I'm kind of Unversed in like I've
never had to come up with a number for
makeup before or a number for how much
my hair cost
or something like that if I say what is
your household what is your household
income well we're a non-profit we raise
our own salary so combined with a
stipend that he gets from the national
budget
it's about 80,000 okay well there ought
to be room in there for hair and makeup
if you don't have any debt except your
home
how much is your house payment I'm just
under 1,400 a month that's not breaking
you up okay
no well I think what we've got here is
you guys are just getting started
learning how to communicate in general
you just got married and he's trying to
take the lead here and you're going to
fall off if you're not very careful into
old habits and that you don't even have
yet what other people would call old
habits and old habits are one person
runs the money and the other one gripes
about it and that's not that's not a
good way to do it that's not a good way
to do it so I think the two of you need
to sit down and look at the budget
together he has got to allow your vote
in this discussion to count but your
vote can't be a whiny princess it has to
be a grown woman who's running a
household with her husband and so it's
reasonable for you to get hair done that
is a reasonable thing it is unreasonable
to do to do that six times a month and
and just keep you know keep your
household broke because you because of
the way you look in the mirror so you've
got to sit and you know balance that as
an adult you're not asking permission
you're making a decision as an adult
with them for the good of for the
overall good of your house and so and I
got to tell you you know he's all he's
off-base here he thinks because he's
doing the first draft that he gets to
tell you what to do and that's not how
this works it's not our marriage works
either by the way why no and I don't I
guess like I don't necessarily like he's
obviously like good another man and but
I think what happens is that he sees
like this unexpected expense on
his end or something no it's not on his
hand he doesn't have an end that's my
point
and you don't have an end we are now
married the preacher said and now you
are one and so when your husband goes
elk hunting we decided that that was a
good thing for him to do because he
enjoys it and it fits in our budget when
his wife goes and gets her hair done
we decided that that's a good idea to do
that on a reasonable number of basis
right and what's happening I think is
that like I'm looking at cutting back on
like so right now I have like $10 a
month for hair and then every six months
I fell and get it done or something
but now as we've gotten into the house
there's like bare walls and things like
that so I trying to find ways to scrimp
and save so that I can five throw
pillows and so like having my friend cut
my hair and that I still pillow is that
it's always it just we need to really
sit down and say I think you've got to
sit down and look at it because an elk
hunt is several thousand dollars throw
pillows times ten plus five haircuts
don't add up to an elk hunt so I mean it
doesn't it just you know there's got to
be some balance here and so he can't be
getting his way and going out here and
living the good life and then you know
you're getting your hair cut with Kmart
scissors by your buddy you know that's
just that's not that that's not in
balance it wouldn't happen in my house
my wife wouldn't be okay with that and I
would and she would be right by the way
and and vice versa you know you can't I
can't you can't you know he can't be the
only one being the grown-up and cutting
back around the house to hit some
financial goals and then but you you
know you're just sticking your lip out
because you don't have something on the
wall on a brand new house you just built
bought by the way I grew up in a house
we never had living a refrigerator the
entire time we lived in it living room
is a place we played and I'll take that
back with the last three years we live
there in the house I grew up mom I
finally got a living room couch and it
was okay it didn't kill any of us so but
but it you know you just have to balance
this out as a
if you if he wasn't there what decision
would you make well you'd be a grown-up
lady raising a child with this series of
expenses then you know you're not in
Congress you can't spend more than you
make and so if you go crazy on some
category like furnishings and then the
next month you can't pay your light bill
then we would all call you stupid right
but on the other hand to not do anything
in your home is out of balance as well I
want you to fix up your nest so it I
think you guys are using I think you've
turned this into a battle between what
you want he wants and you both need to
get above it and say what do we want and
we should want something good for each
other because we love each other husband
serve your wives and so I think that's
what's going on this is digressed down
into a he said she said thing rather
than you guys both get above this as
adults and coach the household for the
overall good of the household which
includes balance good question good
discussion Kate thank you for calling me
this is the Dave Ramsey show